do you think your marriage of marriage  oh I think it's the best Institution for  families but I think the government  ruined it if I was a dude I would have a  really hard time getting married  because it sounds like it [ __ ]  recently I I would it's basically like a  bailout for a woman's bad decisions now  because it's like no matter what I do as  a woman  like there's always a bailout if I sleep  around become a single mother the  government bails me out if I get married  and decide you know what I'm not feeling  it I'm gonna leave my husband I can take  half and the kids and put you on child  support like it's like whatever women do  we're always bailed out